now according to an oversight
investigation on March 1st 2017 less
than two months after then Vice
President Biden left office well not one
not two not three but four different
members of the Biden family they started
receiving payments from an entity named
Robinson Walker LLC now Joe Biden's
brother James received a whopping 360
thousand dollars in incremental payments
zero experienced Hunter you know the
author and artist that he is portraits
of a crack addict he got uh 500 000 Bo
Biden uh Beau Biden's Widow Haley who
was also Hunter's lover at the time
no judgments whatever this is a messed
up family anyway he got she got 35
000 and an unknown Biden could received
70 grand now we don't want we don't know
what these various members of the Biden
family did to actually earn the money
but what we do know is where it came
from it came from the People's Republic
of China now we're going to know a lot
more when we get the suspicious activity
reports they've been very slow to hand
them over to the committee this is the
house government reform oversight
committee but according to the ongoing
investigation
prior to making the bulk of these
payments Robinson Walker LLC which is
operated by a Biden business associate
they received a three million dollar
wire transfer from a major Chinese
Energy company but that's not all in
2015 when Joe Biden was still vice
president Robinson Walker LLC they
received a wire totaling nearly a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars from
an unknown company with a farm bank
account now that was money that was
divided between uh Walker and members of
the Biden family so again we asked what
did the bidens do for all of this money
what did Joe do for any of this money
what favors might be owed to the likes
of China and Russia and Ukraine and all
these foreign countries that they
apparently made a lot of money with now
if you think uh that Joe wouldn't sell
out the country to benefit his low-class
money-hungry family let's follow the
money because that's where the answer
will eventually be found uh because it
happened over and over again look at the
case of Ukraine zero experience Hunter
goes on GMA uh do you have any
experience in Ukraine no oil no energy
no gas no coal no well are you being
paid Millions 100 Biden literally said I
don't know and and to ABC's credit they
said maybe because your your father's
the Vice President in charge of Ukraine
probably yeah so it makes sense how do
you get all that money without any
experience anyway in a statement Hunter
Biden's spokesperson they finally got
back to us we're glad to see that they
say they did not deny the payments they
called the investigation a wild and
baseless right-wing conspiracy where
have we heard that before Hunter Biden a
private citizen with every right to
pursue his own business Endeavors join
several business partners in Seeking a
joint venture with a privately owned
legitimate Energy company in China it
was all above board according to Hunter
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else